[音楽]
ん
そうあなたは先行ですよはいっ
[音楽]
ザー
どう攻めるか
じゃんけんでわかったかテンパった信仰にするって言っ
a
んあこの勝負
どう考えてくれ
選考が不利だ終わりの方1本ずつ購入していき
ランダムで10本のうち1本が強ハズレを押したプレイヤーには鋭い刃が敗者の指いう
色彩道考えにも選考の方が確率的には十分の一弾当たるリスクを開いてる先にとって
いるわけだが降りいや10分の1より次の射手が1/9だから相手のほうが降り
うん
んなんかよくわかんなくなってちゃったかー落ち着け俺
まだ賞馬序盤だずう分の1が当たる確率はたったの10%
大丈夫当たるわけがない
慎重に行くのえ大丈夫
大丈夫だ
大丈夫
ん
あるのか
次はあなたの番手手
なーんーもう従っ
んだ何なんだことは今のいってを埋め全く躊躇なく一周の判断で勝負に出た
こいつ
自分の命がう
たかっていうというのに
さああなたのパンクスのかっ
はいやべもう順番が回ってきた
どうする俺何かなぜ勝つ方法はないのか
[音楽]
なんだ
な
あの日た大
前歯の隣の歯を触っている
なんだどういうことだ
歯が痛いかそれでも何かが引っかかっているのか
いや強いこれは
3だ
いやでも何度サインなんだ前歯の隣の歯が危険ということを知らせているのか
それでも前はお隣の方が安全どういうことなのか全くわからない
俺おまけに中としている可能性までやどっちだまったり想像力ない
はぁっ
[音楽]
シーフ
te
試着ていつまり安全だというのか
前歯の右隣がー
じっ信じているかってだけ
ってでもいいじゃないいくぞん
ん
うん
よかっ
よかったってやっぱやっぱり安全だったっけ
[音楽]
なんええええええな
ねぇなにこの速さへ来ない姿勢なのだ
ええっ絶対答え知ってるよねあなた
ん勝目ないけどこれ俺の負けだこれ
俺とバレないルー
voodoo
なんだ
どこにいっただー
ん
学会で切った
あっ
r
part 1
んだぜということだ
どういうことなんだ r 合う
なんだうわなんか持ち歩くの激しいだったんだこれはアルファのんだ
飲み屋がたらこれもこれも何かヒントが隠さだけにピンポンなのか
なんだなんでこいつ気持ち悪いな
でも何かのヒントの絶対
んまああん
[音楽]
ああ
ないと右右か一話目ということかっ
見え見えたぞこんな分かりやすい品ターン
無料あなのかな
いいよ
あーおればやねこれら無理だよねーああ僕壁ないんだ俺あーやばいこれなー
トレーニ
行ってきます
どうすればどうすればずに家庭
あの歯を押さ速さのどう考えても場所を破っているかあいつがイカれてるからどっちか
たぶん後者だと思う
ここで考えてみれば始まらない
3 le
[音楽]
これは
ん
どうかしましたか
をイヤン
俺がね
おいがおかしいのか
俺が追い詰められておかしくなったん
[音楽]
で豪華仕様ん
なんとなくなんとだからだ
終わりの数かっ
少し多くなっている気がするんだいや丘者が席のデータ機能センター大津京陵極刑
落ち着け女性だでもはまっ見るはじめ
こんなによりがたくさんいるぞ旗ちゃんある俺だけたくされば
まてっまでこれをわぁな
歯の本数が多く見えていてもあぁニュースと負けてしまう
クソどれ
どれもええな
喉乾いたなぁ
んあっ
喉が渇いたいっ
ん
a
l 92
ななんだ歩けずにえーどういう言葉は投げた
曲げたどういうことだ
何なんでこれどういうことだたずに解読すると
l はレフト左から9図2番目の歯ということか
いやでもそんなや幅あった
どう見ても目の前にたくさん派があったあーこの勝負
俺がチャー
223中4516中78中9919にあれ
ん
[音楽]
goo
20分ん
ooooooooooooooooooooo oooo
[音楽]
goo
ad ん